this map shows how consumption in the
United States threatens wildlife in
other countries around the world a cup
of coffee sipped in a cafe in Chicago
for example could be endangering spider
monkeys in Central America the map was
created by scientists from Japan and
Norway let's zoom in to the hotspots in
Central America here species like the
spider monkey are facing habitat loss
because of deforestation a lot of this
deforestation is driven by export
industries including coffee so the
researchers took a closer look at how
the production of goods such as coffee
beans in one country is linked to
consumption in another this is a
relatively new approach to the problem
of biodiversity loss in 2012 they
calculated that close to one-third of
global species threats are due to
international trade here we see how
goods imported by Germany threatened
around 600 species in countries
including Russia Sudan and Madagascar
now the researchers have gone one step
further pinpointing the specific
habitats within countries that are
affected by international trade they
looked at almost 7,000 species of
vulnerable endangered or critically
endangered animals that appear on the
IUCN Red List first they mapped each
animals range here's the stub footed
toad and the red faced spider monkey
then they calculated how much
consumption of goods in another country
contributes to each animals threat level
for example about 2 percent of the stub
footed toad score can be directly
attributed to logging driven by the
consumption of goods in the United
States the rest is probably driven by
consumption in other countries and by
disease let's look at another major
consumer nation Japan if we zoom into
the areas shaded green we see that Japan
has a significant impact on marine life
around Papua New Guinea
Japan doesn't import a lot from Papua
New Guinea but this is a species rich
area so trade has a high impact on
biodiversity mining for gold for example
affects the mangroves which are home to
critically endangered plants and this
vulnerable sea cow the maps also threw
up some surprises you might expect us
consumption to have a high impact on
biodiversity in the Amazon rainforest
but although we see some impact along
the Amazon River the greatest effects
are in the South in the Brazilian
highlands where agriculture and grazing
are extensive this is an endangered
woolly SpiderMonkey us consumption also
threatened species in southern Spain and
Portugal countries rarely perceived as
threat hotspots in Spain a hydroelectric
dam project is affecting the habitats of
the critically endangered Iberian lynx
one purpose of these dams is irrigation
control for agriculture including olive
oil which is exported to the US using
these maps the researchers hope that
conservationists will be able to target
those trade routes that have the biggest
impact on biodiversity ultimately
leading to more sustainable trade and
protecting the world's wildlife
you